so i am curious what as actors what is
it like to actually
adapt
your characters from animation you know
like because it has to be a little
weird or different than anything you've
done before
yeah i mean i think you know there's a
great uh a great sense of care
that
goes into just the initial approach
because you do have so many people who
hold these characters so close to their
hearts so you really want to do them
justice you really want to respect
what was already there
but i think you know for
our characters are not in the anime a
whole lot so there's also a lot of room
for us as actors to i think build and
play and find what's right
um the dynamic of this relationship was
really
fun to sort of crack yeah you know
throughout the whole season so
um
yeah it was just uh
it was just you know the the
extra the extra care that you really
want the people to feel like you
respected what was there and built on
that instead of changing it completely
second everything uh elena says i think
uh you know it's
trying to find the core of the character
that should remain you know without
which they're not the character from the
anime i think that's really important
but then to
live up to what has been written
uh by the brilliant team of writers for
our um live-action version which is the
sort of plus you know the the extra the
expanded backstories and the the um the
new layers of these characters and their
histories
one of the cool things about cowboy
bebop or one of the many cool things is
it's unlike anything else that's on
television um when you talk to itself
isn't it that's what they said in the
original yeah
yeah 100
when you've been talking to your friends
and family about the series what are
some of the things you keep telling them
like i can't wait for you to see this
we're not allowed to talk to our friends
about the series
they just know we've been in new zealand
doing some mysterious project um for me
it was um
the fight i just so enjoyed getting to
do getting to do the fighting actually
you won't have seen my the big fight yet
because you've got another couple of
episodes to go but um the physical side
um all of in fact the stunt team and the
stunt choreography is so imaginative um
that yeah that's uh something i'm
looking forward to people getting a kick
out of yeah for me it was uh
the one thing i told my mom was oh i get
to sing i can't wait for you to see me
sing on a stage so that was
that was one thing that i was hopefully
allowed to say yeah to my own mother
uh one of the other things about this is
um
like the world is so unique for people
that have never seen it how like what
would you like to sort of tell them
about it
hmm i guess it's slick and pulpy and um
like a western and a noir
space western 70s um martial arts film
uh and uh for us like a real gothic kind
of drama yeah it uh touches a lot of
bases
pretty much something for everyone yeah
there has no it has a dog in it i mean
what more he doesn't like dogs come on
right well one of the cool things and
you sort of touched on it already is
that your characters are i think are the
biggest changes from the animated show
in terms of you know the expanded roles
so can you sort of talk about like how
um i guess
how that ended up um allowing you to
have that freedom that even though it
was in the animated series you didn't
really feel beholden to it or i guess
could you talk a little bit about that
well it's not that we didn't feel
beholden to it i just think that there
there was so much room to build because
these characters are um you know we just
see glimpses of them in the anime so
really taking what's at the core there
and being able to create
dynamic layered characters and a layered
storyline um
while
respecting you know the idea that
already existed um was i think
was what was really exciting about this
was really getting to
knowing that people were going to see
a new side of these characters that they
didn't see in the anime
um and not to spoil things for you but
episode nine is quite a back story heavy
episode for um vicious julia and spike
and that love triangle um so to get to
have that fleshed out um and get a sense
of why these characters are the way that
they are particularly you know why
vicious
um has such beef with spike and has such
a kind of hold over julia and that was
really an interesting way to kind of
root
the
heightened kind of um violent nature of
of the character in some um
a kind of pain and uh uh
uh
you know self-protection i guess
yeah i could sort of feel like that
episode had to have be had to be coming
with the way it's been building up you
know all season um when i spoke uh i
heard that basically all the department
heads were told to plant easter eggs and
it was like a big part of the series so
what would you want to tell people about
maybe where they should look in
scenes that involve you guys
well so
vicious in the anime has a cormorant um
with him quite famously um that he feeds
and um is this kind of specter of death
and i i think fans will be looking for
some evidence of the cormorant um and i
would say around my costume you might
see little nods toward that um that you
could look out for
uh what i really loved that costumes did
was there's the story and the anime that
i believe spike tells about the tiger
striped cat and the white cat
and there's a coat i wear a
tiger-striped coat
on i believe it's on my date my first
date with vicious yeah um so i thought
that was a really that was a really cool
little easter egg
that's actually i didn't even real i
didn't i didn't put it anyway um
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the show obviously everyone
has heard about you know you guys have
to shut down for a little while because
of john's curtis knee uh what else do
you think might surprise people to learn
about the actual making of the series
well
one thing is to
for vicious being obviously an
incredibly violent character who's
constantly covered in blood one thing is
that my wig wasn't allowed to get any
blood on it at all because it would turn
pink if it did um so if ever i had blood
they had to like weave these specific
parts uh into my wig
and there was an amusing time during
this big fight where um a practical
blood effect uh didn't slight you know
didn't quite end up where it's supposed
to and it all just went onto my hair so
i immediately had to be rushed off um
and just you know doused with some sort
of i don't know hair treatment um
so yeah that that
that might not be what people would
expect i guess
i think i i think i i must have had some
similar stuff with hair too because the
wigs you know
yeah i remember the climbing out of a
car and somebody being like make sure
there's no blood in there because we
gotta do this again and
lo and behold just a pool of blood
that note i got to stop again congrats
uh i look forward to seeing the rest of
the series i hope it's a huge hit thank
you so much
you